way back in 2015
Warner Brothers release an Aquaman
poster for their upcoming film Batman V
Superman dawn of mustache at the time we
had no idea of what this entailed what
the terrible Martha
scene would do to our dreams or what the
unite the 7 slogan that was emblazoned
over the top of the poster meant the
internet was awash with theories but
most thought the tagline referred to the
supergroups founding members Batman
Superman Wonder Woman flash green lanten
Aquaman and Martian Manhunter
when the film got released we quickly
realized that only seven in the film was
and it's rotten tomorrow's score and
fans waited with bated breath for
Justice League to reveal the answer once
again we received no more information
however the question of its meaning
finally seems to be answered with the
newest details on the Aquaman solo movie
which is set to be released in December
on a recent set visit Joe Blow calm
learned the tagline was referring to the
Seven Kingdoms of Atlantis and not the
Seven superheroes that make of the
Justice League according to the blog in
the movie the aquatic civilization
Atlantis fell into the sea five thousand
years ago and became Seven Kingdoms
trench brine Shelby Union the fisherman
kingdom the Atlanteans and the missing
Kingdom as it's been three years since
the poster first hit the internet many
fans has worked this out already but
it's great that we finally get some
confirmation
even though we all know deep down that
Warner Brothers probably had no idea
what they were doing as per usual and
are now just changing their universe to
fit a huge mistake that they should have
never done in the first place and oh my
god is that two joker movies being
confirmed anyway the only question that
remains is who will unite the Seven
Kingdoms will it be Jason Momoa z'
muscle-bound titular hero or perhaps big
bad Bell and all played by Patrick
Wilson who do you think comment below
and let me know and if you enjoyed this
video please like it and subscribe to my
channel I create content like this
weekly and that'll be something on here
that you love if you're a fan of film
thanks very much for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]
you